[Applaudissements]
méfie-toi les inconnus comme moi vous
avez sans doute entendu cette phrase
quand vous étiez petit et bien ce matin
là elle m'est revenue en boomerang
parce que j'ai ouvert ma porte un
inconnu
tout a commencé sur facebook
la magie des algorithmes une annonce
indiqué qu'une école de français pour
demandeurs d'asile et réfugiés chercher
un hébergement d'urgence pour un élève
avec cédric mon mari ça faisait
longtemps qu'on avait envie d'agir mais
on savait pas comment s'y prendre comme
beaucoup d'entre vous j'imagine
j'ai répondu à l'annonce et tout s'est
passé très vite
24 heures plus tard abdelak un migrants
tchadiens de 21 ans frappé à ma porte
au moment de lui ouvrir et lorsqu'il est
entré chez moi j'étais loin de me douter
que cette expérience cette rencontre
allait bouleverser ma vie et celle de ma
famille
à ce moment là en fait j'ai plutôt
réaliser la portée de mon geste les
premiers moments furent timides
silencieux on ne se comprend pas abdelak
ne parle pas français et je ne parle pas
arabe
alors j'ai improvise je me mets à
cuisiner je fais des pâtes
on en revient aux fondamentaux et puis
la table je réalise cap des lacs mange
très peu je comprends qu'il a dû il a dû
manquer il a dû avoir faim et puis je
vois qu'il est épuisé
alors je vais indique sa chambre il
s'écroule
il dort tout l'après midi à son réveil
j'ai envie d'en savoir plus sur lui
alors il me tend un épais dossier comme
ça son dossier de demande d'asile et je
comprends que qu'il est passé par la
libye je suis journaliste je réalise des
reportages et des documentaires dans le
domaine des droits humains et je sais
qu'en libye les migrants sont réduits en
esclavage sont victimes de racisme
certains sont parfois enrôlé par des
extrémistes en refermant cet épais
dossier finalement je me pose encore
plus de questions
et puis la nuit tombe
la première nuit et puis ça je n'avais
pas anticipé tout à coup je me sent
vulnérable
il faut dire que cédric est en reportage
je suis seul avec abdelhak chez moi et
oui je me sent vulnérable
il dort dans la chambre d'à côté je
l'entends respirer puis finalement je me
dis mais qui est il et s'il s'en prenait
à moi et si c'était un terroriste
je me suis posé cette question
totalement irraisonnée mais je le dis je
parviens pas à m'endormir je crois que
je n'ai pas fermé l'oeil de la nuit
et puis le lendemain matin à des lacs
est face à moi au petit déjeuner il a le
regard dans le vide n'est pas à l'aise
aussi mal à l'aise que moi finalement
et puis j'ai un peu honte de mes
craintes de la veille mais je me dis que
finalement c'est humain après tout
d'avoir peur peur de l'étranger
et puis il faut que je parte travailler
je décide de lui faire confiance je lui
confie une paire de clés je pars
travailler et puis je rentre un petit
peu plus tôt que prévu pour vérifier et
j'ai un bon indicateur à la maison c'est
mon chat vous voyez là elle ressemble à
ça quand elle a peur tout de suite en
arrivant je regarde mon chat elle dort
sur le canapé complètement paisible bon
et puis rien n'a bougé chez moi dans la
maison et puis abdellah qui en fait est
dans sa chambre
il dort et puis cédric rentrer une
colocation cohabitation s'installe on
partage le quotidien tous les trois
abdelak prend des cours de français il
apprend l'apiculture et puis on réalise
qu'il est seul qu'il est tout seul à
paris je comprends qu'il n'a pas parlé à
ses proches depuis cinq ans ils ne
savent pas qu'il a kid est arrivé sain
et sauf qu'il est en france qu'il est
vivant et puis je comprends qu'il est
isolé aussi dans cette démarche de
demande d'asile donc voilà on a envie de
l'aider de lui trouver des solutions
donc la cohabitation dur un petit peu
plus que ce qui était prévu
alors très vite avec cédric nous avons
une discussion importante parce qu'à ce
moment là l'année dernière en hébergeant
abdelak et bien on se met hors la loi
on risque cinq ans d'emprisonnement et
30000 euros damende mais on prend la
décision de l'héberger en dépit des
conséquences
c'est finalement un cdi qui s'installe
entre nous non mais pas de date de fin à
cette cohabitation
je me dis que certains voisins ont
peut-être avoir des craintes orient
arriver un inconnu dans la copropriété
ma copropriété c'est un petit peu mon
laboratoire d'intégration et puis tout
se passe bien
une voisine me confie que voilà elle et
elle est rassurée maintenant qu'elle a
rencontré abdelak parce que voilà c'est
pas là la figure inquiétante ce ce
migrant qu'elle s'imaginait ou qu'elle
voyait à la télévision
finalement voilà il a un prénom il
s'appelle abdelak voilà et puis très
vite je me rends compte que la
solidarité est contagieuse je trouve une
paire de chaussures un matin sur mon
paillasson
une enveloppe est déposé dans ma boîte
aux lettres pour parer à ces dépenses
les plus urgentes
ma dentiste lui offre une consultation
aujourd'hui ça fait plus d'un an qu'elle
des lacs vie chez nous il est dans la
salle ce soir mais il tient à rester
discret il parle français aujourd'hui et
on se comprend beaucoup mieux j'ai
appris ce qu'il a vécu l'enfer qu'il a
traversé
il a fui les persécutions au tchad
un jour les autorités ont découvert que
son père apporté une aide logistique à
la rébellion anti régime
le chat c'est pas exactement ce qu'on
peut appeler une démocratie et un matin
la police a fait une descente dans la
maison familiale ils ont découvert une
cache d'armes dans le jardin est un
téléphone satellite
toute la famille a été emprisonné et
séparées dans des prisons différentes à
14 ans abdelak se retrouve seul dans une
geôle noir sombre et les jolies elles
cherchent à le faire parler
alors il commence par lui jeté des seaux
d'eau froide au visage ça ne marche pas
alors viennent les coups puis les coups
et encore des coups jusqu'à lui briser
les tibias plusieurs mois plus tard
abdelak parvient à s'échapper commence
alors le long chemin de l'exil
via la libye il va rester cinq ans
coincé dans le bourbier libyen avant de
réussir à embarquer sur un bateau
pneumatique en méditerranée il parvient
à rallier les côtes italiennes
puis il arrive en france à paris et
c'est là que nos destins se croisent
accueillir un inconnu sous son toit
c'est se frotter à la douleur de l'exil
à la douleur de son de son passé de son
parcours
ça a pas été drôle tous les jours je
vous cache pas qu'on a beaucoup pleuré
et puis plus matériellement c'est
partager son espace son intimité
notre appartement n'était pas du tout
adaptée à une cohabitation
et puis ça coûte un peu d'argent on être
un couvert de plus à table pendant un an
plus d'un an
mais tout ça c'est rien par rapport à au
bonheur qu'on a qu'on a vécu tous les
trois je peux vous le dire aujourd'hui
la solidarité fait du bien
je me souviens de notre première éclat
de rire le jour où on a osé
au bout de quelques semaines indiqué à
abdellah qui est musulman qu'il priait
dans la mauvaise direction
cédric a sorti sa boussole pour lui
indiquer avec diplomatie que ça se
passait de l'autre côté
voilà c'est ce jour là on a vraiment
brisé la glace et puis après voilà
c'était le début d'une grande complicité
et aujourd'hui c'est un petit frère pour
nous et puis j'ai réalisé que notre
histoire est loin d'être isolé ce qui
fait la une des journaux en ce moment
c'est plutôt le repli sur soi
la montée du populisme mais il existe
une france invisible chaleureuse
solidaire tout autour de nous des
français agissent j'ai appris que nous
naissons câblé pour l'entr'aide pour la
solidarité
spontanément dans la cour de récréation
vous avez sans doute aider un copain qui
tombaient voilà vous l'avez rattraper
mais le hic c'est qu'en grandissant
notre société et toof cette capacité
d'entre aide alors j'ai eu envie de
prendre ma caméra
c'est mon métier et d'aller à la
rencontre de ces citoyens qui tendent la
main d'aller aussi entendre ceux qui
bénéficient de l'entr'aide qu'ils soient
exilés ou parmi les français les plus
précaires
je lance une web série documentaire sur
youtube elle s'appelle carnet de
solidarité et elle est financée
entièrement par les spectateurs parce
que j'ai envie de faire rayonner ses
histoires parce que la solidarité
partout qu'elle est indispensable et
qu'il faut en parler
merci
[Applaudissements]